[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
so Oliver what is parody I'm used to
hearing about that in the context
particle physics properties what does it
have to do with astronomy if anything
absolutely so party is fundamentally one
of the big symmetries we think about in
the universe so fundamentally this is
the symmetry of mirror Reflections so
basically if something looks the same if
you swap left and right round or reflect
something in a mirror so on a human
scale the example is the human body if
you look at it from afile you'd think
okay humans look the same if you reflect
them in the mirror you swap say that
left and right shoulders but if you had
to look in more microscopic details and
see when you do that the heart would
move from one side of the body to the
other so the human on a human scale
internally is not parasymmetric
so cosmologically this is also super
relevant and in this case we're thinking
not about reflecting a human in the
mirror but reflecting the entire
universe in a mirror per se
and in this case we actually expect that
things should be symmetric
so another way of saying this would be
if you'd never seen the universe and I
gave you
a the universe or B the universe that
I've flipped in a mirror you wouldn't be
able to tell which one was which they
both look statistically
indistinguishable and the reason that
they should be indistinguishable is
because primarily the universe is
controlled by gravity and gravity
doesn't care about parity so gravity is
the same if things are moving left to
right or right to left and such anything
that's not parasymmetric in the universe
tells us there's some other force of
Interest going on like say on super
small scales we can get like
interactions from the weak Force which
as particle physicists have known since
the 60s does violate parity and if we
were to see something like that in the
universe on super large scales it will
tell us that something weird and new is
going on that isn't just gravity
and have there been other credible you
know kind of observations of parity
violation in astronomical context before
yes it's an interesting question so
there's been a couple there's been a
couple of different routes with which to
explore it I'm searching there was a
famous one about looking at the
directions of spins of galaxies like
Galaxy rotations it's looked at I think
in Galaxy Zoo images and that was
actually a particularly interesting
experiment because they found out that
most of the images if I remember
correctly were identified as it was kind
of rotating towards the left the spiral
arm was moving to the left rather than
the right and that's this kind of parity
asymmetry left and right on equivalent
in that case that was actually
eventually put down to some psychology
and the human brain likes to identify
patterns in One Direction rather than
the other direction so in the end that
was incredible but there have been some
other kind of very intriguing things
from cosmology and one of the big ones
is Cosmic birefringence so it's
measuring polarization data from the
cosmic microwave background
and right now that's giving some sort of
tentative evidence that might be
something interesting going on
um but exactly what and whether that
will continue to hold up in future data
is quite hotly contested at the moment
yeah in the late 90s there was a famous
claim of a detection of radio Galaxy
polarization orientations that were
preferentially biased in one helicity
state uh in that case it was left and
right circular polarization that were
claimed to be asymmetric and then the
person who actually had the theory that
would have predicted such an effect Sean
Carroll passed four-time guest on the
podcast he uh actually had the most to
gain perhaps Nobel prizes uh and he was
the one of the chief Architects to
refute this claim almost as soon as it
came up in the late 1990s so these
claims can be quite perilous and that's
why you know Marx
um you know very very uh almost Brazen
for Mark kaminkowski so it has to be
very very interesting and provocative
hence your appearance here so you have
some wonderful images and slides that
you're going to show I wonder if you can
share them with the audience and kind of
walk through it and my audience is as
you know the the brightest and the known
corner of the Multiverse so don't be
afraid to geek out and uh I can get into
the details up fantastic
great so you should hopefully now be
able to see your screen yeah yeah so
just give a couple of details um
about this sort of work and it's
actually where these slides are from
um I'm going to discuss mostly the new
stuff with galaxies but also maybe
comment a little bit more about this
Cosmic biofringence which I just
mentioned a minute or two ago
um because it's it's still sort of quite
hotly contested thing
so I think I mean obviously it's to
anyone listening to this it's obviously
an exciting topic to have made it onto
Brian's podcast
um and it made it into a couple of other
science magazines which is quite
exciting new scientists described the
universe as surprisingly lopsided
um and that so that was about all of the
recent work it's also this article by
scitec daily saying it's hints of new
physics in the early universe so it's
obviously something exciting and
hopefully I'll be able to unpack a
little bit more about why it's exciting
and what could possibly mean and also a
little bit realistic do we think it's
actually real what else could cause it
obviously we need to be good scientists
and think
is it new physics or is it something we
haven't thought about yet in our
analysis
I think it's worth considering both of
those pretty carefully
so I said a little bit about parody
before so I'll go quite quickly here but
um so parody symmetry is symmetry if you
reflect something so left and right
switch as we've said
um and one of the fundamental things
about particle physics is that it
doesn't have to obey parody symmetry
just as we said the human is not parody
symmetric the weak Force isn't parody
symmetric but generally everything we
know about in physics in the standard
model is charge parity times metric or
CPT symmetric and this basically means
that if you do an experiment and you
flip left and right but you also flip
plus and minus and you flip the
direction of time you end up having a
symmetry like stuff like the weak force
of basal symmetry and you can sort of
ask what would that mean in cosmological
contexts well for something like gravity
gravity doesn't care about charge and
gravity doesn't care about time so that
itself means this CPT symmetry is
automatically going to mean that gravity
is going to be parity symmetric so what
I was alluding to before
so
as I said cosmology should be parity
symmetric and the main manifestation of
that is images of the universe which are
flipped in a mirror like this image in
the top and the bottom here which is in
fact I think a realization of um the
illustrious TNG simulations these should
be statistically indistinguishable so I
shouldn't be able to tell you which is
which if I hadn't seen it before
obviously if you have two next to each
other you can say okay this one's
flipped version of the other one but if
I only had one of them I wouldn't be
able to tell you is this the flipped one
or is this not the flipped one
so a lot of the work in this has been to
kind of ask the question can we make any
robust statistics and measurement tools
which are able to actually say do we
have something
flipped or unflipped can we sign a
create a test for this whole parity
symmetry
so I said parody violation exists in
nature and it also exists we think in
cosmology so one of the big example of
this is barrier Genesis
so in this case this is about the
formation of a matter in the universe
and how we have predominantly mostly
baryons and very few anti-varians so we
have mostly protons very few
anti-protons we have electrons not
positrons Etc
and that itself is a slightly
interesting process so those are really
nice work by um takarov in 1967 which
basically said there's a couple of
conditions in order for this sort of
process to happen to be able to generate
this anti-symmetry and one of the big
um conditions is that we need to break
charge parity symmetry so I said before
charge parity time is a symmetry but
charge parity doesn't have to be and
that we need some process which breaks
that in the early universe
and if it's something that doesn't care
about charge that could mean it's going
to break parody symmetry so the reason I
bring this up is really to say that by
virtue of the fact that we see matter in
the universe and not antimatter we
already know some interesting parody
phenomena are going on in the early
universe so it's not beyond the range of
possibilities that we could have
something interesting going on that we
could observe today say in the
distributions of galaxies or in the
cosmic microwave background
so in common cosmology where could we
actually get this manifesting
so the formation of matter against
antimatter is something we normally
affix to the super early universe
in general there's actually a couple of
different times that we could have some
kind of parity violating process
so Cosmic inflation is one of the big
ones kind of this hypothesized super exp
super luminal expansion in the first 10
to the minus very small seconds or 10 to
the minus a lot seconds
but that's not the only option we could
also have things happening at the end of
inflation of a chaotic period called
reheating that we really don't
understand well and in general in fact
these first two bullet points are not
well understood theoretically we have
hints from late data about what the
early Universe did but we don't have
sort of good observational probes to it
and we're really trying to extract as
much information as possible to try and
uncover the secrets of this a little bit
the other option is something weird in
the late time so for example some kind
of modified gravity
maybe we have some version of gravity
which doesn't respect sort of things
being invariant under left and right
switches
so often when we do this we actually
require some kind of vectors or tenses
in the universe so generally a lot of
physics is scalars so whether that's
sort of the temperature of the CMB or
the number of galaxies it's just a
number it doesn't have any kind of
Direction attached to it and because
these parities
necessarily involve left and
right-handed things we often require
some kind of left and right-handed
elements in order to generate this
asymmetry so maybe we have some kind of
vector field in the super early Universe
during inflation the Dynamics of that
Vector field could leave some kind of
parity violation in the universe
so I'm just showing this graphic at the
top the green line is a sort of
left-handed Vector field you can see the
green lines so showing the direction of
the field by going left-handed round the
line moving to the left and in the
bottom the red panel here is showing the
right-handed one so if you only had just
left-handed ones in the universe you
could make a measurement of parity
because let's say I had a universe with
just left-handed things and when I
observed it I only saw right-handed
things that would tell me that I wasn't
looking at the original Universe I was
looking at the mirror flipped Universe
because we know it should all have been
left and it's now all right Etc
so that really begs the question how do
we look for this in data so we need to
find some kind of statistic which is
different between the standard universe
and the flipped universe so measuring
the sort of vector fields in the
universe is quite a nice way to do this
but we don't really have many Vector
fields which makes our lives quite
difficult
a lot of our standard statistics are
things like power spectrum bi-spectrum
and the tri-spectrum AHA these are
really giving correlations of particles
so they're saying on average how far
apart are two galaxies or on average how
far apart are three galaxies or four
galaxies
and it's an interesting question about
which of these are actually parity
sensitive so which of these can tell us
something interesting
so
talk a little bit about scalar
observables so these in particular the
main ones of Interest are galaxies and
the CMB there are a couple of other ones
of
um 21 centimeters and lines from the
sort of metals absorbed in galaxies but
I mostly talk about these guys because
they're kind of the big players in
um cosmology right at the moment in
terms of data
so the simplest we can do is look at
something called the two-point
correlation function
um and the two-point correlation
function is just the distribution of
pairs of galaxies so I picked two
galaxies and I say how far apart are
they
unfortunately this doesn't really tell
us anything because if you imagine
taking a pair of points and you flip
them so you flip from the left flip from
a in front of B to B in front of a
they're still exactly the same distance
apart
so here parity is actually the same as
just rotating my two points around
and the consequence of that is that
there's no interesting signal
so part of your inversion rotation are
the same which means my two point
functions can't tell us anything
so if we want to look harder maybe we
want to look at say three point
functions
so this is a little cartoon of what a
three-point function looks like we've
now got three galaxies and we're now
asking the question
what shape do these three galaxies make
if I were to pick three galaxies at
random they can be separated by some
distances so the lengths R1 and R2 here
what are those distances and what
distances are most or least likely
so we can play the same trick again here
to think let's look at these galaxies on
the left and then let's just flip them
in a mirror and look at the ones on the
right
do they look the same and unfortunately
we once again have a problem because in
this case flipping the diagram on the
left looks like the right but you could
also Imagine rotating the diagram on the
left and getting the diagram on the
right so if you imagine sort of taking
your triangle pulling it out of the page
turning it over and pushing it back in
again we have the diagram on the right
and this tells us that once again for
three objects parody inversion and
rotation is the same
thus if the universe is rotationally
symmetric which we think it is we're not
going to see anything about parity with
a three-point function
so at this point you can kind of guess
where I'm going uh so we're interested
to see anything interesting with parity
we actually need a four point function
um
so this can either be done with a CMB or
also with Galaxy service there's a nice
paper by bobcan
collaborators of his pointing us out
back in 2011.
um so in this case you know how four
galaxies in the universe and you pick
four at random form a tetrahedron with
them and they form kind of this by shape
Channel left here when you flip it on a
mirror you get something on the right
and these are interesting because as
long as the Four Points don't all lie on
the same plane so as long as I can't
draw them all in a bit of paper
parity inversion and rotation are
physically different things so basically
there's no way to get from the left to
the right diagram so if I were to do
something simple like say count the
number of tetrahedra on the left and the
number on the right
I can learn something about parity so
effectively I would say
I'm going to count the number of left
tetrahedra subtract off the number of
right tetrahedra and say is the answer
zero
like obviously when you do this in
practice there's all sorts of noise
going on we only have a finite number of
galaxies so everything's kind of random
but you can sort of ask statistically do
I have more left-handed tetrahedra than
I have right-handed tetrahedra and is
this a significantly more is it much
more than I'd expect simply from random
chance
so that's really the essence kind of one
of the big statistics of parity
violation that we've been exploring of
either with the four-point correlation
function or the tri-spectrum which does
the same thing but slightly more Furrow
transforms involved and for the CMB
turns out to be slightly better
I will briefly say the other thing which
is tensor parity violation so if we have
access to things in the universe that
have directions as well as just sort of
numbers Associated to them like
polarization we know that has kind of
um it's a tensor it has two directions
associated with it or the shapes of
galaxies so called Galaxy Shear or even
the spins of galaxies it's been some
nice work on that recently we can do a
couple of different tests
and the reason for that well the
diagram's a little bit wonky here but
when we have um a vector or a tensor
observable
once we flip something in a mirror we
also flip the directions in the mirror
so something that was sort of
left-handed before we flipped it is now
right-handed and the consequences of
that are that with a two-point function
we can now see parity violation if we
have some interesting Vector so the big
Consequence the standard thing used here
is the two point function of temperature
and polarization of the cosmic microwave
background the cltb guy here and this
has been known about for quite a long
time and and there have been attempts um
to measure this and from different
sources one of the main ones I'll talk
about a little bit bureaufringence is
sort of quite interesting at the moment
has some interesting implications
so to summarize this bit if I'm just
looking at scalars like number of
galaxies or the temperature of CNB I'm
forced to use sets of four galaxies or
sets of four points on the CMB which
makes the computation kind of difficult
if I'm using vectors or tenses I can
just use two points but that calculation
still kind of is difficult mostly
because we normally need things like B
modes and we haven't made a good
detection of B modes in the universe
from primordial sources at this point
tell me about it although of course
Brian Knows a Lot About That
okay so
now let me talk a little bit about what
we've actually seen
so the first observation Cosmic
birefringence so this the credit to this
absolutely goes to a bunch of people um
I think mostly in Munich Ichiro Komatsu
and the authors kind of given at the
bottom here
so in this case the authors looked at
the correlation of polarization from
cosmic microwave background in
particular the correlation of emotes and
B modes from the CMB this is kind of a
very difficult measurement to make which
is basically why we're seeing it mostly
now rather than when the Planck data
release first came out the authors have
been very carefully calibrating for
every possible systematic and some
really intriguing new methods for how
they do this
but the result seems to be get a signal
and we shouldn't get a signal if the
universe is parity symmetric basically
anything with B modes and something that
isn't B mode should always cancel
so something where it's happening
so the hypothesis with this is that in
the early Universe we have the CMB and
it's paralysometric it doesn't have any
weird physics
but as the little Photon moves from the
CMB sort of 380 000 years ago or 380 000
years after Big Bang until the Observer
Today it interacts with matter going
from early Universe to the late universe
and the action of that is it rotates the
polarization of the photon so even
though it was originally parasymmetric
some interesting rotation effects means
that when we observe it it's not parody
symmetric
if this is real this would be super
exciting
so it's rotated by an angle which is
pretty small it's about 0.3 degrees and
it's roughly detected I think right now
is about 2.7 Sigma there's been a couple
of different analyzes this is one of the
recent ones I think the Diego Palace
paper
so what could be causing this well in
this case it's possible that we can have
the cause of an Axion in the universe
connected to these CMB photons
so this Axion is just sort of a weird
scalar particle that's existing the
universe and not really doing too much
until it encounters the photon and
axions have a particular ability by
what's known as the churn sinus coupling
to interact with the photon rotate its
polarization giving it exactly the
signal that we think we might be able to
see in the data
so this will be a simultaneous detection
not just a parody violation but also of
axions in the universe we've never been
into direct to directly detect them
although a lot of theories have
hypothesized them
unfortunately there are complexities
with this so the major complexity in
this case is dust in the universe so
we've been talking about polarization
rotation from axions
unfortunately we can also get
polarization rotation and sort of
um parody violating
radiation itself emitted from dust
it's a little bit different kind of the
standard cmbb mode thing because now we
have to have parity violating stuff but
the galaxy has dust everywhere it's not
rotationally symmetric it's not
spatially symmetric so it's very likely
a priority that we could have similar
sorts of signals coming from dust
so is this the end of the story well
people don't really know there's been a
lot of people saying yes and saying no I
think the most recent um
results say we need better data and we
need better understanding of dust so in
fact this plot here is showing you the
sort of signal that we could expect from
dust in some forecasts these are some of
the early ones I think in black and in
blue that measured signal we were seeing
that 0.3 degrees rotation
and you can see the dust kind of could
be pretty important it depends where we
look on the sky of course
and it's not at the moment totally well
understood how we can separate out the
two signals so I think from my point of
view at least right now it's exciting
evidence that could suggest party
violation but we really need better data
and hopefully a future will tell us a
lot more about that
yeah
okay so observation number two this is
the one that I've mostly been involved
with
um and I'll talk mostly from my site but
also there's also parallel work done by
uh German who and Zack Slappy and bobcon
uh over in the US
and this guy is all to do with these
four point functions and in particular
Galaxy four point functions and has led
to this interesting surprisingly
lopsided claim from the New Scientist so
what have we done in principle we simply
counted up every set of four galaxies in
the universe and for each one have said
is it does it form a left-handed
tetrahedron or does it form a
right-handed tetrahedron and we said do
we have the same number of left-handed
and right-handed tetrahedra in principle
it's a little bit more technical we do
it as a function of scale we do as a
function of shape but in practice that's
really what we're doing we say do we
have a left and a right-handed asymmetry
and the claim which has led to some of
these articles is that we do have an
asymmetry we're finding that the number
of left and right hand isn't the same or
when we Square it this number is
considerably bigger than zero and bigger
than anything we'd expect just from
random fluctuations
so I won't go into the big details of
the actual how this is computed but
there's been some interesting
developments
um which I was involved with on the
on-call codes in particular which allows
this to be computed pretty robustly
um but
so skipping to the actual interesting
bit what have we done with the data so
we have in practice around a million
galaxies to play with these have all
been observed by the sdss project in
particular the boss survey I think the
barrier barium oscillation spectroscopic
survey I think and these measure
galaxies kind of like those shown in the
white and blue dots here I think the
white dots are really the main ones used
in this analysis
and we can condense these into
measurements of this parity odd or
parity even four point function so it
contains two contributions this one on
the right here is the parity even
contribution so this is what happens if
I add together the number of left ones
and the number of right tetrahedra so we
would expect there to be a signal here
Gravity should give us some kind of
signal we found it back in the paper in
2021 and that was exciting it says
gravity in the parity even bit at the
way we think it should these plots are
notoriously difficult to understand it's
a problem because
four point function involves four
different uh galaxies and it's a
tetrahedron which has six different
sides you have to specify
um so you have to sort of collapse it
all into one axis this is just a
snapshot of some of the data but really
the interesting thing here is on the
left these points don't really go
through zero and they're not just random
fluctuations they're significantly away
from zero and that's telling us that on
the left side which is very small scale
tetrahedra I'm sort of about 20
megapartex or I guess 60 million light
years in size we have some interesting
gravitational effects
Oliver can you talk about the
computational you know uh input and
output uh it seems like you know a
million uh people may think oh you know
that's big but it's not that but when
you're doing the four point you know
higher how many permutations how many
different combinations how long what
kind of computer are you using what are
some of the details of the uh of this
calculation don't be afraid to nerd out
as they say absolutely
um yeah so I'd skip that slide um but
let me actually talk about it so it's
actually a really computationally
intensive procedure so let's say I have
a million galaxies if I want to compute
every possible tetrahedron of a million
galaxies that's a total of a million to
the power four objects so it's 10 to the
24 sets of these objects you see on the
left here and for each one I have to
assemble a tetrahedron and then
basically look at all the different
sides so it's characterized by the six
sides you can see here or if you prefer
three lengths and three angles
now even with the best computers in the
world 10 to the 24 tetrahedron
evaluations takes way too long this
would take I think of the order of many
years actually
um possibly considerably more than that
so it's something that was just totally
not possible
um which was a bit of a shame because it
seemed like a fun problem
but in the end
the actual method we use to evaluate
this uses kind of an interesting trick
which I've tried to sketch in this
picture here so the crucial point of
this is that a tetrahedron contains four
galaxies
and I can equivalently write it not as
four galaxies but it is three pairs of
galaxies so if I tell you the Galaxy at
the bottom I hold that one fixed and
then I tell you the distance to the
second Galaxy the third Galaxy and the
fourth Galaxy you can go ahead and make
up your own tetrahedron and the cruising
point is that we can do all these
independently basically if I hold the
first one fixed I can then go ahead and
count up every single second Galaxy
every single third Galaxy and every
single fourth Galaxy
and doing those all basically in
parallel and all independently
and this is useful because at any point
I only ever need to consider a pair of
galaxies and the number of pairs of
galaxies is 10 to the 12 which is
considerably better than the number of
quadruplets which was of the order of 10
to the 24.
so once I got all those pairs of
galaxies at the end it's just a problem
of assembling them all together
and you can do this with kind of a bunch
of tricks in practice what's actually
going on here is we're utilizing a bunch
of techniques borrowed from chemistry
actually everything is expressed in
spherical harmonics has a lot of really
fun discrete maths going on
um especially so quantum chemistry is
where a lot of these techniques get
borrowed from
um but suffice it to say you can do this
of recoupling all at the end to get out
at tetrahedra and then the computation
actually is viable so I think for the
data set used uh in this these analyzes
computation took I think it's of order
about
I think it's about 100 computer hours
um and this was primarily done on a
supercomputer in Princeton and Princeton
University
um of course we have to do this not just
for the data but also for a whole load
of simulations so we had to do it for a
thousand simulations as well so in the
end it's uh more like 100 000 CPU hours
which is starting to get a little bit
more costly but significantly less than
doing this for all the 10 to the 24
galaxies so I guess 100 000 times 10 to
the well 10 to the 12 will be the extra
time we need that's probably longer than
[Music]
um
it's probably longer than the length of
my career put it that way
daughter can work on this yeah
absolutely
um yeah so basically it's it's quite a
lot of work needed to get these
statistics but we're now in the point
that we can do them and with the sort of
advanced computing power that we're now
getting things like GPU power we can
actually do this considerably faster
um it's things like putting all these
calculations on GPU rather than a CPU
probably allows this to be sped up by
perhaps an order of magnitude so maybe
instead of 100 hours it's gonna be more
like 10 hours
and that'll be super useful in the
future as we have more and more galaxies
so if we have 10 to the eight galaxies
instead of 10 to the six then there's 10
to the 12 becomes I guess 10 to the 16
which is uh 10 000 times harder so that
at that point we really need to throw in
all the computational tricks we can
which sort of we're working on doing
great so I said a little bit about the
parity even four point function so the
stuff we already understand but what can
we say about the parity odd four-point
function so this is just looking at the
difference between a left-handed and a
right-handed tetrahedra and I should
just say there are sort of fundamentally
good ways of establishing what a left
and a right-handed tetrahedron is it's
actually to do with um sort of basic
vectors and so left and the right-handed
rule
um if you want to be technical about it
you take the distance to the three
galaxies you do a triple product and you
see if it's positive it's right-handed
and if it's negative it's left-handed so
we can do this in a fundamentally good
way
but this is some of the data so I'm only
showing you a little fraction of it
there's actually about 20 plots like
this again they're a little complicated
to interpret but on the left we have
small scales and on the right we have
large scales and what you can see is a
whole jumble of stuff like the sort of
bands here are results from simulations
so these simulations don't have any
weird parity violating physics in them
because we didn't put it in but the data
possibly could do and the data are
little points in blue and red here which
are from two different areas of the sky
one in the north one in the south
so from this plot you can't really tell
if the contributions are zero or in fact
two non-zero so we're going to need to
do some interesting statistical analyzes
to try and work this out
and a lot of the statistical challenge
is that we have ordered like a thousand
data points we started off with a
million galaxies and then we measured
the distribution of tetrahedra in a
thousand different bins and each bin is
telling us a different configuration of
different side lights for example
so it's hard work but objects it's very
high dimensional each of these different
data points is super correlated with
each other which makes our life
significantly more difficult
because we have a lot of basically
there's different ways you can write
down a tetrahedron you can say one
tetrahedron you can then flip it around
to a different shape or different sort
of just rotate it and it looks like a
different object it's got different side
lengths maybe the first side length is
now the second one Etc because I've
rotated it around
but those detergent were the same
and in practice this just gives us some
kind of complicated correlations in our
data that we have to be able to deal
with
so kind of the standard approach is to
do chi-squared analysis this is what's
done a lot in particle physics and
cosmology as well so you basically take
your statistic you try and work out the
noise and the statistic
um as given by its covariance Matrix so
this is just saying if I were to have
totally random fluctuations in my data
um how correlated would those
fluctuations be so what sort of signal
would I get on average what would be the
square of that signal on average
and I just put them together in a
combination that this guy should be able
to be modeled by some basic statistics
that's Chi Squared should follow a
chi-squared distribution
of course the Devil is a little bit in
the detail of this so one of the
complexities is that we need to be able
to model this covariance so the noise
fluctuations
and we basically have two ways we can do
it firstly we can do it from Theory so
we can scratch our heads and do some pen
and paper Theory or black wooden chalk
whatever your preferred theoretical
method is
this has been done it's paper nice paper
led by John Hove doing this last year
however of course anything we do
analytically comes with assumptions you
have to make assumptions about how the
universe behaves on large scales and
what terms we put into our Theory
the other option is we can do it with
simulations so we can say we have a lot
of kind of good guesses of what the
universe might look like so each of our
simulations is a thousand galaxies in
the universe in a position they could be
we've just sort of taken the universe
from its earliest moments and evolved it
and at the end popped in some galaxies
and we measure this thing from every
single simulation and we could try and
use this to get apple covariance
this has somewhat different assumptions
we don't need to assume that we can
understand everything on paper but we do
need to assume that the simulations are
accurate enough basically saying do the
simulations look like arom Universe
there's a second assumption which is
whether this likelihood is actually
gaussian or whether this Chi Squared is
chi-square distributed so this basically
comes down to how correlated is the data
we generally like to make some nice
simplifying assumptions on likelihoods
and statistics this actually might be a
scenario when things could possibly
break down because everything's a bit
High dimensional
foreign
so
let me now show you the result
um so this is the result from one of the
papers uh German host version which is
showing you the expected distribution in
this black curve here and in the orange
what we got from the data so basically
we made this measurement of Chi Squared
from data we then said does it match our
theoretical expectations and if it
doesn't it's telling you there's
something weird going on with parity in
the universe
which would be strange so this
technically is about seven Sigma seven
Sigma is way past the physicists five
Sigma so immediately somebody should be
getting a Nobel Prize and um everything
should be great
unfortunately things are never quite
that easy so it's useful to think we've
think about sort of different ways to
process the data in fact there was
another analysis that was done by me
simultaneously
um which is actually doing things in a
little bit different way so the previous
analysis was doing things by
um assuming that we understood the
covariance and we could model it with
our pen and paper Theory or a lot of
equations that's really pages of
equations it's quite a painful
calculation actually
the second approach was saying I'm going
to base everything on simulations
instead so this makes slightly different
assumptions we assume slightly less
about the statistical modeling however
we do assume the simulations are
accurate and this plot on the right here
I'm showing you the statistic we get
from our simulations
and what we get from the data to the red
line so once again we're seeing the red
line doesn't really fit with the
simulations in fact it's larger than
2040 out of the 2048 simulations
so tentatively we have a detection of
something at 2.9 Sigma it's a
significantly less than seven Sigma
because we made fewer assumptions but
it's still something interesting
so
what sort of are the implications of
this
before I say that I should just say
let's we should dig in a little bit more
about the differences between these two
approaches so seven Sigma versus three
sigma is obviously very different
so the kind of two things that could be
causing it it's really what I mentioned
before first that I likely it might not
be gaussian got a lot of correlations
going on things are in a lot of high
Dimensions quite difficult to model it
and secondly maybe our covariance isn't
adequate now I'm not going to say that
one of these approaches is right and the
other one is wrong I think the fact that
different approaches get different
answers tells us that we have to be very
careful tells us that at least one of
them isn't perfect
now maybe our covariance with pure
Theory wasn't accurate but maybe it's
not accurate with simulations either
however we are still seeing an
interesting result
and I want to say a little bit more
about what could possibly cause that
result so I said before we can have
something interesting going on in the
very early Universe maybe in inflation
or we could have some interesting
physics in the super late Universe for
example with modified gravity
so
inflation tends to be the easiest
scenario basically because in the
inflationary period we really don't have
a great idea of what's going on we know
lots about what isn't going a lot going
on but we do know everything's happening
super high energy super high
temperatures
so effectively we can add as much random
new physics as we want as long as it
hasn't already been constrained by
something we can try adding in and
seeing if it can be detected in that
data in the late Universe we have to
have some kind of modify gravity but
this modified gravity has to be
important on very large scales because
the minimum distance between the
galaxies and these analyzes I was
talking about was about 20 megaparse x
or about 60 million light years
and that's actually quite a large
distance given that since the very early
Universe our Galaxies have moved a bit
but they've only really moved about 20
megaparse x since inflation so about
that minimum scale
so grab so I'm going to modify gravity
would have to have really important
effects on very large scales we don't
quite have a great idea of how that
would work right now but of course
there's always sort of different ways
that um you could come up with that
could potentially do this I'm sure more
will be explored in the future
so that brings us to inflation so I'll
skip the technical details here because
inflation remodeling gets a little bit
complicated but basically there's a
bunch of theorems um that says with our
simplest model of inflation we wouldn't
get anything interesting violating
Cosmic parity
however if we have more interesting
inflation we could do so for example if
inflation depends on
um scale or basically how it evolves in
time or if inflation involves multiple
particles so like we often like to think
about it as just a single particle in
the universe so just as the universe
happily super expands or a single field
if we have other ones with different
spins for example this could give us
something interesting or if even
inflation happens in a slightly
different way to what we thought about
something called ghost condenses and of
course there's a bunch of other things
so actually this is what I was thinking
uh with a couple of colleagues down in
the institute for advanced study in
Princeton in particular Giovanni
cabasson Misha Ivanov about whether we
can kind of learn something interesting
about inflation from this data like
we've already we've made this tentative
detection of something could we use this
to make a stronger detection of a
particularly interesting form of new
physics
in general if you're just trying to make
a detection of do we have parity
violation yes or no that's quite hard
but if you're trying to make a detection
of a specific model you can in general
do much better basically because you
know where to look in your data your
model says maybe large scale is the most
important or small scales are most
important so you basically Focus your
analyzes on those regions
so again I won't go into details but two
of the in I'll just say briefly two of
the interesting things are exchanging a
spin one particle during inflation so
this means inflation I don't actually
have a scalar I also have a vector going
along
um
this kind of
basically we've been able to use this
data set to do quite a few very
interesting
um analyzes and in particular try and
work out if we can find any evidence for
specific models of parity violation in
inflation
and right now the situation wasn't quite
as promising as we might have hoped
every model we've tested we don't detect
so I think we tested a total of 18
models so far and all of them return
values consistently zero so we try and
detect the amplitude like this one chain
on the right hand side here you can see
it's something very close to zero across
a zero so at this point
if the signal is real it's eluding us so
let me just conclude a little bit with
um
what actually what my thoughts on what
this signal could be are so it could be
something new and exciting in the
universe and as Mark kamikaska was
saying if this is true this would be
incredibly exciting it will tell us that
weird new physics in the universe is
going on that we don't know and that we
haven't already hypothesized the simple
models we have hypothesized don't seem
to work so maybe it's some other model
of inflation we haven't thought about
it's a model of late time physics same
some kind of modified gravity
or some other interesting physics
happening at a different time that we at
this point just haven't thought about
of course there are however
non-cosmological options
and it's possible that we have errors in
how we analyze the data or errors in how
we do the analysis so I did say a little
bit about whether our simulations or a
theory is good enough I think that's
something that definitely needs to be
explored more in the future
um so to me
the kind of state status of this right
now is we detect something detecting
something very interesting
and in the future we're going to get a
lot more data so we're going to have
results from the Dark Energy
spectroscopic instrument which has been
observing millions of galaxies going on
right now
so that's going to give us a huge big
data set which we can look for the same
thing in and see do we see it and
hopefully we're going to see it much
better because the data set's a lot
bigger
and also we can look at other things
that aren't galaxies so for example the
cosmic microwave background is another
option so that's something I've been
considering a lot in at the moment to
say let's look at the CMB temperature if
we see the signal there that would
confirm the Galaxy signal with a totally
different set of assumptions and really
if we were to see the same thing in both
things this would be great this would be
pretty good evidence that something
interesting is in fact going on
so as with ever as with all things the
time will tell
um I'm very excited to see what the
future is going to bring and hopefully
we will know pretty soon
absolutely well this has been really
phenomenal absolutely crystal clear you
can stop sharing the screen and I'll
have links to that um the presentation
and other work that Oliver works on in
the video description below and while
you're down there leave a thumbs up if
you'd like to have a comment if you'd
like to have Oliver back on the channel
to discuss his other work massive Uber
as they say it's been uh really
delightful following this the progress
and would love to have you back in the
near future after you go to Stockholm
but even before you go to Stockholm that
would be a wonderful so we can talk
Oliver philcox of the Simon Society of
fellows of Cambridge of Columbia
University and I hope we can meet up in
person I'll be there probably later this
year and I would love to meet you in
person maybe we'll do a part two in
person and have even better audio and
visual Delights exciting stuff thank you
so much for having me this has been
great and I'll have links to follow you
on Twitter and everywhere else and um
yeah let's stay in touch this is this
has been so delightful thank thank you
so much Oliver have a wonderful uh rest
of your day bye
[Music]